hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comment today are going to
be starting a new series on the 1972
World Chess Championships out of all the
video requests I get this is probably
the most requested one and for good
measure it was deemed the match of the
century we have the champion buddy
Spassky vs. the Challenger Bobby Fischer
we have the cold war going on so the
United States vs the Soviets the Soviets
at this time they had pretty much won
the World Chess Championship for 29
straight years they were deemed the best
in the world at chess no one really came
close to them and then all of a sudden
this one American stood up to the
Soviets and challenged them and he had
been just on a crazy streak up into this
point but he's basky 33 years old at the
time of the tournament Bobby Fischer 29
years old at the time of the tournament
and the World Championships backs then
were a lot different so it was a best of
24 games now to furn comparison later on
this year we will have the World
Championships and that is 12 games so we
have double the amount of games back
then this took over a month and a half
to play which is crazy to think about
how long they are actually playing this
was deemed the match of the century and
for good measure to give you a little
bit of background on how Bobby Fischer
got there he was the Challenger but he
had to go through the candidates
tournament much like we do in today's
chess you go through that tournament and
he dominated that tournament so his
first two rounds that's a little bit
difference nowadays and then back then
they actually had a tournament that you
went through played one opponent if you
beat them you went to the next opponent
his first two opponents he beat six oh
nine oh if you're not too familiar with
chess scoring you get half a point for
tying you get zero points for losing you
get a full point for winning they
alternate white and black and he went
six oh six Oh which means in 12 straight
matches alternating his opponents he's
playing grandmasters they didn't even
draw a game in the finals he played
Petrosian Petrosian was the previous
champion before buddy Spassky so he was
at the top of his game
name one of the strongest Soviets at the
time he beat him six and a half to two
and a half so coming in Bobby Fischer
was one of the hottest players he
actually had a higher rating than buddy
Spassky did at the time Bobby Fischer
was also a pretty interesting fellow if
you've seen any of the specials that
have been on TV lately he was kind of
quirky he also had really weird requests
specifically for this tournament he had
a specific chess pieces built for the
tournament he also had them remake the
chessboard because he didn't like the
chessboard that was built which is just
bizarre to me he also didn't show up for
the opening ceremony which I didn't
really think you could do that
especially with this big of event but he
didn't even show up so all in all it was
chaotic you have the United States
versus the Soviets it's going to be a
bloodbath but we have a ton of games to
cover we will get started with the first
one and at game number one whites can be
played by the champion buddies Spassky
and a Bobby Fischer is going to be
playing the black pieces
Spassky starts out with pawn to d4
Knight f6 pawn a c4 punny six not f3
pawn d5 Knight c3 and then the Bishop
down here to b4 transposing into the
nimzo-indian defense always a strong
defense from black gives them a lot of
fighting chances a lot of aggressive
lines you can take pawn here to e3
castle on the King side Bishop d3 pawn
c5 castle and then after knight c6 we
see pawn to a3 now the main line ajuna
we're going to see Bishop take here on
c3 giving double pawns pawn takes here
on c3 and then black can decide how he
wants to take he could always just give
back the double pawn play pawn takes
here on c4 Bishop takes back Queen here
to c7 this is extremely common
it does give white kind of that light
square diagonal control with his light
square bishop but instead Bobby Fischer
wants to kind of hold on to his bishop
so he plays Bishop back here to a5 and
then Knight over here to e2 Knights no
longer pinned down to the Kings who can
freely move over here now the pawn takes
the bishop takes an division
back here to b6 protecting this square
here on c5 after the exchange Bobby
Fischer sides to go ahead and take the
Queens off the board so after the rook
takes the bishop here to a c5 and very
good control of the center of the board
all of a sudden Spassky has they both
have safe pawns they do have or save
Kings they do have the same pawn
structure on the Kings side white does
have control to Center the board with
his rook right here but he is up one
move in advantage so besides that both
sides are pretty equal no one's really
got an add a line they're still pretty
much sticking with the main line
variation pun appear to be for forcing
the bishop back to e7 I does not want to
get into any tricky variations after
Bishop here to b2 does not want to move
his Knights right away and instead of
having a pawn taking back on f6 decides
hey I'm gonna go and bring my bishop
back here to e7 so that if you do decide
to go ahead and take if that's going to
be completely fine I'll be left with a
double bishop pair and I will have to
give up that double pawn disadvantage
here on the F house that's why you saw
that they should come back here to e7
now Bishop to d7 rook over here to see
one row cure to DA just counter-attack
in the center of the board
there's only two open files you have to
see in the D file so both sides are
going to be looking to get their rooks
very involved they also are just trying
to maintain control the center of the
board Bobby Fischer's doing a great job
with his Knights controlling the center
and then the bishops are defending those
knights
Knight here to a d4 when you see an
exchange on board now Bishop down here
to a four attacking the rook now Bishop
down here to b3 decides to go ahead and
take those off the board I work down
here to d1 in exchange right here rook
here to c8 so both sides you can already
tell they're not doing anything crazy it
is Game one and there's 24 games in the
series so they're trying to feel each
other out right now no one's really
getting into any crazy lines the reason
it hasn't been any variations where you
could say you know if we kind of went
down this line and kind of complicate
things there's not really any
complicated lines so far in Game one
right now it is pretty draw it would be
pretty pretty crazy to be honest to
actually see this not going to draw
neither side really has a clear
advantage from here but we see continued
play with King to f1 now that the queens
are off the board the Kings can get
control in the center of the board since
the bishops are the same color it's
going to be even more difficult from one
side that really control one of the the
colors and then kind of promote the
pawns if they wanted to
but both sides are going to be looked to
control to share the board with their
Kings get them involved as much as
possible and control as much of the
board with their rooks rooks definitely
don't want to be hanging out here on the
a a file or the H a file they want to be
controlling all the files and these
ranks as much as possible so King here
to f8 King up here to e2 Knight down
here to e4 work over here to c1 just
kind of stopping and getting the you
know the threat of rook down here to see
to it gets a little bit tricky then he's
going to be forced to either move his
King and lose a bishop or play something
like rook here to d2 just doesn't want
to have to deal with it Knight here the
d2 possibility but things just playing
straight defense so decides to go and
just bring over here rook to c1 and then
after the exchange on board it looks
more and more likely that will just see
a draw from here Bobby Fischer plays
pawn to f6 Knight a5 attacking the pawn
here on at b7 Knight comes back to
defend that King to d3 Spassky G of
centralizing his king a bishop here to
d8 Knight back here to c4 and then we do
see an exchange on board and then pawn
to b5 not much that either side can do
right here this is pretty Josh but fun
facts about Bobby Fischer if you don't
know much about him one besides the fact
that he's an interesting character to
say the least he also hates drawls he's
definitely not the guy who after 20
moves against a grandmaster if it looks
pretty drawl she's going to shake his
hand he's going to be playing for the
win I see a lot of this in Magnus
Carlsen Magnus Carlsen always trying to
grind down his opponents playing these
really long games just psychologically
trying to beat his opponent also much
like Magnus Carlsen Bobby Fischer just
feels like he's better than his
opponents and in the end game in many
respects he was at that point
so he definitely even sometimes if it
was not the best move he would always
try something just to see if he could
beat his opponent so that's exactly what
Bobby Fischer does he could have easily
shook his opponents hand Spassky would
have snap called that right away and
gotten the draw that would have been a
big confidence booster for Spassky
seeing as how Bobby Fischer just beaten
anyone even with the black pieces lady
lately to go ahead and say that hey I
can draw would be good but Bobby Fischer
plays Bishop down here to h2 which is
very interesting because after g3 the
bishops kind of stuck he's going to fall
and Bobby Fischer just kind of gives up
that mess here and it's not real clear
exactly what he was expecting to do you
know they were kind of looking at the
fact that maybe he was expecting that
after pawn to h5 King here to e2 pawn
down here h4 that you could see King f3
and then maybe pawn to h3 King to g4
Bishop down here to g1 after the the
King takes you to the bishop take but
then after Bishop to d2 no longer can he
really escape maybe he thought they'd
come to Bishop to e1 and there would be
an escape for him but all in all this
did not happen he saw this later on as
you could see after pawn to h4 and the
king came to f3 decided to go and play
King to e7 he was not going to be able
to escape with his Bishop so he decides
okay second best from here I need to go
and get my king centralized I am going
to have a pawn advantage here although I
will be down my bishop I do need to go
ahead and start attacking with my pawn
so King here to g2 I decided to go and
get as much material as possible after
the pawn takes the bishop kit takes and
then the King recapture so crazy turn of
events we do have Bobby Fischer on the
Kings side with three pawns looking to
storm the King side Spassky on the other
side does have a bishop which can
control most of the board especially
considering it's open with no other
pieces to worry about and he also has
very active piece in the King Bobby
Fischer plays King 2d6
upon appear to a four king d5 just
trying to centralize Bishop you to a
three kingi for attacking the pawn a
bishop over here to a c5 this is a nice
little square for this pawn on e3
because the dark square Bishop can
always have a nice little outpost this
is also attacking material here on a7
so all in all this is just going to be
very good since it is being attacked
pawn here to a six and then pawn appear
to be six there's no real reason for
Spassky to have to do anything too crazy
he's kind of controlling the board right
here so it's actually better for him if
he can keep two sides of the board for
Bobby Fischer to worry about if it was
one side of the board can kind of
overwhelm his opponent with more pawns
but just keeping it over here there's no
reason to try to exchange anything so
pawn to d6 a very strong move now pawn
to f5 King here to h4 and this is a
really strong move there's nothing
really nice that Bobby Fischer can do in
this particular spot he decides to play
pawn to f4 which is probably a mistake
but if you kind of look at it there's
just no great movie can play pawn to g6
but then King to g5 just threatening to
just start taking material that's not
going to be very good you could play
King to e5 instead but can really just
start to do the same thing is not really
doing too much on board but as I just
play King to f4 now we do see a take on
board King takes but you just don't want
to start losing the pawns on board it's
just so difficult to defend both of
these pawns especially since they're not
next to each other that's even more
difficult so all in all very very good
setup for Spassky here he just has to
kind of play it out King here to h5 just
threatening to come up here and attack
King to f5 does need to stop this he
can't just give up this pawn for
freebies Bishop down here to e3 King
here to e4 trying to attack Bishop to f2
just kind of maneuvering a little bit
here Bishop h4 now
it's kind of stopping some of the
threats that the king can go to we do
ce-5 starting to push forward a little
bit Bishop here to g5 now e4 Bishop down
here III just stopping that and now the
king can't really do too much to get
involved and really protect this pawn
right here so it comes up here to e6
but now King to g4 starting to attack
has to come back here to e5 protecting
this Bobby Fischer just doesn't have the
big threats that he would like he's kind
of playing defense right now just trying
to hold on to his pawns as long as
possible
heating up here to g5 he can just kind
of play this go back and forth just see
what Bobby Fischer's doing he always
kind of has that advantage here King
over here to d5 now King to f5 just
strengthening his position even more
pawn here to a5 now Bishop back here to
F to G five decides to go and start to
take material King here to see for King
here to f5 and now after he takes
there's really nothing that Bobby
Fischer can do after the King takes King
up here to d5 King to b5 but then after
King to d6 there's just no way to stop
white here he is protecting the pawn
here on b6 with this Bishop he's
protecting his light square right here
he can easily just come here to c7 take
this pawn on b7 and then promote and
because the square here on a1 is a dark
square all of a sudden it's very easy
for Spassky to go ahead and hold down us
fourth there's no way for Bobby Fischer
to ever promote that material so round
one a Game one actually goes to buddy
Spassky congratulations to him now
what's kind of interesting is Bobby
Fischer did not like how Game one went
specifically there were cameras
everywhere and he demanded for Game two
that all cameras were removed he didn't
want them around he didn't really want
spectators at all and they said no they
pretty much told Bobby Fischer that he
was crazy they're not going to do that
and so Bobby Fischer forfeited Game two
so buddy Spassky wins the first two
games in the 1972 World Championships
because mob history
want to play bobby fisher' and everyone
in the whole world kind of assumed that
he would get on a plane to just leave
that he was kind of that stubborn that
he just if he didn't like what was going
on he just wouldn't have anything to do
with it he ended up getting on the plane
getting ready to leave his second which
is kind of the person that kind of helps
you out in a chess tournament they help
you prepare other kind of your sidekick
actually convinced Bobby Fischer to come
back out and to play and so he actually
got Spassky to agree to play from then
on in a back room without the cameras
and such so going into round three Bobby
Fischer has a huge disadvantage down two
games but psychologically he is kind of
getting in spassky's mind so this is
kind of the the first video in the 1972
series we will be going over every
single game except for Game two because
Bobby Fischer just forfeit so if you're
one of the many that has requested this
video series hope you enjoy it so many
games to go over but this is game one
buddy Spassky winning